this is one of those classes of hoc
questions where like one of the
trickiest things about the HSC is that
because you know everything by that
point sorry let me start again because
you've been taught everything by that
point we can ask questions about
anything and so it's not like ah this is
an exercise and the title is using the
product rule in differentiating I think
so everything's going to be using that
part of the problem is you've got to
work out what the thing is now hopefully
the question itself gives you it throws
at you over and over again this word
they give your remainders they ask for
remainders so you know almost with
complete certainty you're gonna need the
remainder theorem at some point and it's
been you know a few days since we used
it properly so that's why I've reset it
up here on the board okay but
importantly in the question they provide
you two remainders they say when you
divide by X plus one they give you a
remainder of you've got it right
negative eleven thank you and then when
you divide is X minus three yep xx minus
three
yep you get a different remainder it's
one very good now we can use both of
these facts to unpack both of the parts
of the questions so part one says find
the value of B which is that very last
bit along the end okay now when you look
at the they've said P of X in a really
weird way they said P of X is equal to
and then I think if I've got my memory
right here they've got X minus three so
the two factors that they mentioned then
I think it says Q of X is that right now
Q of X coincidentally he P sorry Q comes
after P and R comes after cubed P Q and
R brilliantly actually stand for
specific things P stands for it's a
polynomial Q stands for when you divide
something what ends what's the answer
call it's called the question right
you've got this question part but then
there's this extra bit hanging on here
now I think is it is it a lots of X plus
plus one plus one and then there's a be
hanging out and that's what we're trying
to find right now this is very important
okay when you can see the polynomial is
written in this form this actually has a
name we called this guy all the way back
we call it the division transformation
it says
if you divide some polynomial by
something right you'll get a question
and then what's this thing called here
this is the remainder okay now this is
so important to note because if you have
a look at part two of the question this
is the actual thing we are trying to
find that's like the the real question
and part one is just kind of like a
milestone along the way okay so let's
get to rub that out let's get to part
one and actually use these two facts to
get to B now I could use either of them
but one of them is easier to use which
one do you think might be more helpful
being that the thing I'm trying to get
at is B what are you reckon gay hmm so
you're actually both wrong and yo you're
both actually say the same thing but
from different angles this is what you
said sorry X plus 1 but the way I use
this with the remainder theorem is I'm
going to evaluate P of a what is P of a
in this case it will be P of negative 1
right so I'm gonna say if I evaluate
this this is me using the remainder
theorem in this case I know what
remainder I'm supposed to get out it
should be negative 11 that's the answer
I'm supposed to get right but I can
actually do the substitution like
everywhere I saw an X I can replace it
with a negative 1 so let's go ahead and
do that
PF negative 1 equals negative 1 plus 1
that's 0 so the second I write that I
actually don't really care about any of
the other things in here because
there'll be 0 times some other stuff
just going to give you 0 so far so good
so this whole thing is dealt with what
about this what happens this guy a times
0 so again you're like oh that thing
just sort of disappears this is why this
is the right choice plus be hanging out
in the end so you got zeros and a big
this is the thing you really wanted but
you know what this a is equal to you
knew from the remainder theorem so P is
just negative 11 nailed it so that was
part one that's all we had to do
but you had to know to use the remaineth
you in this particular way okay
then part two continues it says okay now
that you know this can you find out this
whole thing here so what I'm going to do
is I'm going to rewrite it now that I
know what B is this is part two so P of
x equals x plus 1 X minus 3 here's my
question which I have no idea what it is
but I actually don't need to know and
then here's my last little Brit hanging
on here minus 11
okay now I've so far already used this
fact so what's the other fact that I
haven't used yet yeah this one here so
to use this with the remainder theorem
I'm going to evaluate P of what P of 3
there's the a value there right so I'm
going to write down therefore P of 3
equals and I'm going to do the same
substitution I did earlier and you're
now saying to see why this was written
in such a weird awkward way when you put
in 3 into here you get 4 but when you
put 3 into here you get 0 so you
actually don't care what the rest of it
is it's all going to get multiplied by 0
not so how long the end here I do have
to worry about this so you end up with
the A's there I'm going to try and find
out what that is in a second this
becomes 4 thank you much 3 plus 1 and
then that minus 11 is hanging out on the
end
ok now thankfully from the original
question I know what P R 3 is supposed
to be equal to in the beginning it's
supposed to be equal to 1 so I'm gonna
write 1 equals 0 Plus this stuff so far
so good
and now it's just I can just tidy up the
odd row therefore from the front for
this this one here is that what you're
talking what so yeah that 4a is right
there
said ok can someone tell me what to do
I'm gonna add something to both sides so
we're going to add 11 will do that'll
make a 12 over here but to make a the
subject I'm gonna write the 2 over here
right so then we can divide through by 4
which gives a equals 3 have I finished
no but I'm so very close right the
actual question says what is the
remainder
when you divide through by all of this
so a is not the answer
B's not this I need to sub in three into
here and I've already substituted minus
eleven into there okay so I would tie
this up in a nice neat bow by saying
therefore the remainder is and then I'm
going to substitute in three lots of X
plus one that's what I know what a is
now right - eleven bag I can simplify
that kind of it's not that hard
I three lots of X 3 minus 11 minus 8 we
got there in the end
tada yes you did but you didn't know
that that was the right part Zacky
perfect so that's exactly right I can
say from this fact here there's kind of
like and I put it probably should have
drawn out a little more carefully
there's sort of an invisible line going
to here I've used the remainder theorem
if you divide through by X minus 3 this
is the remainder yet
so therefore P of 3 equals that said all
right so very very helpfully noticed and
then I've just do algebra on the right
hand side you're happy